we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're gonna go to our next caller from
the 9 5 4 area code caller from 9 5 4 go
ahead hi can you hear me
we can hear you who's this uh hi I'm
calling from South Florida and I think I
might be asking the exact opposite
question of what the gentleman before me
asked okay go ahead all right so I was
wondering uh in the sense of as you were
saying increasing political
participation right in what ways could
you know you think that we could be
using technologies for example like the
blockchain like the internet and those
communication methods to you know
increase political participation in a
way that we're not doing right now I've
heard some people say that we could even
use technology like the blockchain to
even be moving away from like a
representative democracy system to
something more like a liquid democracy
system where you know more people have
more of a say on you know the issues
that matter to them essentially uh so I
was at a wedding going unless you really
change the political system yes the
specifics of blockchain technology for
voting I'm unsure about I think that in
the immediate voter suppression tactics
need to stop we know that the limiting
of voting hours we know that the
requirement of IDs which in and of
themselves are free but require not free
documents in order to obtain to begin
with all of that stuff suppresses voter
turnout I'm against it all the ruse of
in-person voter fraud as a justification
for those policies has been widely
debunked we've debunked it in a
long-form deep-dive it's widely recorded
that that it just does not happen and
when it does it disproportionately it
seems to be Republicans who are trying
to prove a point about how easy it is to
commit voter fraud and then they get
caught because it's actually not that
easy blockchain implementations I don't
know I don't know I'd have to research
more about that um just just before you
go actually I just want to know do you
think even if it isn't the blockchain
because boxing's do you know just one
technologies I've been hearing about but
do you think in the long run you know
things like the internet will you know
drive political participation and you
know kind of maybe drive us away from
the current representative democracy
system yes I do and there's some places
including Estonia that are already
experimenting with that I do think that
if we're if we are going to go in that
direction
then not only do we need to consider the
Internet
a public utility which the opponents to
net neutrality don't want to do it
basically needs to be considered a right
what about concerns of hacking though
yeah you always have CACI hacking
concerns but we already have that with
the current system we have we always
hear about this election was hacked that
election was hacked the numbers were
messed but so you'll always have that
that's not a reason not to pursue
something if it would be otherwise good
all right thanks for the call from South
Florida very much appreciate it